[Musique]
voilà
bonjour nous avons plaisir de recevoir
aujourd'hui christophe caupenne pour
notre dixième des jeunes et de lives in
business club et nous sommes ravis
donc l'histoire caupenne ancien
négociateur du raid qui parmi nous
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
bonjour christophe dont jean-françois
donc rabii ii d'être ici de t'avoir
parmi nous l'objectif de ce déjeuner
c'est de découvrir à la fois ton
expérience au sein du raid mais au-delà
de ça également c'est l'aspect
négociations qui aujourd'hui nous vivons
dans l'actualité prend tout son sens
quand c'est difficile plus compliqué est
ce que tu peux nous présenter dans un
premier temps ton parcours avant le raid
pendant le raid et après le raid donc
d'une manière synthétique c'est un
parcours qui est vraiment très chanceux
puisque j'ai eu le plaisir de d'exercer
en police judiciaire en groupe de
répression du banditisme
ensuite en groupes criminels donc ce
sont les deux aspects on va dire les
plus passionnants ce que l'on trouve
dans les romans policiers ou les films
et restera avec donc des enquêtes
vraiment d'un très grand niveau de
dangerosité des très grands intérêts
judiciaire et puis lorsque j'ai intégré
le raid c'était en tant qu'officier donc
pour prendre une partie très original de
l'activité à un silo qui était en plein
développement et qu'il était celui de la
négociation de crise alors il faut
savoir qu'une unité d'intervention
sémantiquement parlant c'est fait pour
intervenir mais la réalité des choses
c'est que l'on paye un très lourd tribut
en fait lorsque l'on intervient ça coûte
très cher en blesser en mort on en a eu
trois quand même depuis la création de
cette unité
donc ça veut dire que l'intérêt d'avoir
un mode de résolution pacifique était
fondamental et
au delà de ce qui existait déjà
puisqu'il y avait déjà un groupe qui
était constitué il fallait surtout
formaliser les connaissances pour en
faire un vrai véritable savoir faire et
donc ça a été ma mission pendant trois
ans j'ai travaillé là-dessus
spécifiquement pour essayer de
construire avec mes collaborateurs avec
un psychologue clinicien que nous
allions avec nous tout un cursus et ce
cursus basé sur l'ensemble des sciences
humaines avec un passage pour la fac de
médecine pour faire de l' expertise
mentale des choses comme ça avec
beaucoup de contacts avec des collègues
étrangers beaucoup de déplacements et
des changes avait que chacun dans leur
spécialité ou dans leur domaine
originaux de criminalité eh bien on a
réussi à bâtir un bac + 3 qui est devenu
un bac + 5 inscrits au répertoire
national des certifications
professionnelles donc un vrai métier de
négociateur de crise qui nous a permis
d'avoir vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
très bons résultats près de 80% nos taux
de résolution pour la négociation
c'est énorme en préparant ce déjeuner
j'ai vu dans ton palmarès j'ose dire
ainsi 350
résolution ou intervention comme
intervention est à fait donc eux qui
étaient de tous ordres ça allait des
choses qui étaient les moins vulnérables
et mot est moins grave pour nous en
termes d'exposition c'est à dire des
forcenés des preneurs d'otage des
également des suicidaires et des choses
beaucoup plus compliquées comme par
exemple des chantage contre l'état avec
des groupes criminels terroristes mais
également des kidnappings à l'étranger
et ça c'était une très grande difficulté
puisque là il faut travailler sans filet
on n'a plus le groupe d'intervention
avec soin et donc on est totalement
livré à l'efficacité ou l'honnêteté de
la police locale ainsi que la justice
donc c'est vraiment un travail qui est à
ce moment-là extrêmement exclu le
négociateur s'expose énormément avant de
creuser le l'aspect je dirais
formation parce que ça c'est vraiment
captivant de pouvoir théorisé de et de
pouvoir enseigner donc de faire le
massage de un passage de témoin et de de
connaissances qu'elle était en leur sort
de ta motivation au départ pour
rejoindre leur aide est-ce que c'était
la dimension risque dimension créer
quelque chose c'est quoi qui t'a poussé
à rejoindre ce corps d'élite
c'est une c'est une chance inouïe quand
on intègre une unité comme ça parce que
elle est d'une exigence absolue
on sait qu'elle va aller sur les crises
les plus graves qui soit mais c'est une
exigence absolue parce que on doit
donner tout le temps
durant tout notre temps de commandement
le meilleur de nous mêmes et il n'y a
pas de moment de repos d'une certaine
manière on peut pas dire tiens je prends
des vacances je suis plus là débrouillez
vous non non c'est tellement unique
ce positionnement au sein de l'unité
notamment quand selon un officier et
bien que à ce moment là la disponibilité
est totale et ce qui ce qui a été le
moteur véritablement c'est
l'apprentissage constant que l'on a
d'accord sur les opérations puisque on
débrief on apprend vraiment au fur et à
mesure en ayant les mains
véritablement dans le cambouis mais
également sur la très grande diversité d
occasion de s'améliorer du fait de
l'évolution des neurosciences de de
progrès en matière de communication et
autres donc en fait on a une multitude
de chances d'évolution et c'est un
apprentissage constant
c'est extrêmement stimulant là tu me
tend une perche que je vais saisir le
juste après il parle de l'évolution des
neurosciences un sujet qui me passionne
dans la l'univers de la négociation plus
commerciale donc moins dangereuse
quoique parfois douze ans au raid
il s'en sort et demi deux ans et demi le
compte est bon quel impact sur la vie
parce que j'entends une disponible tous
les instants comment ça se vit sa vie à
côté d'argent ce jeune fille n'a échappé
on va dire aux aux offres justement de
ces difficultés mais c'est vrai que
c'est très prenant
donc ça veut dire que l'on à une
disponibilité qui est totale constante
et qui embête et appeler n'importe quand
n'importe la paille on ne sait jamais
pour combien de temps on va partir donc
c'est très difficile voilà vraiment
vraiment extrêmement difficile difficile
pour la famille également parce que il
faut avoir une très grande stabilité
émotionnelle chez soi ne faut pas avoir
des enfants et une épouse qui nous pose
des complications domestique on va dire
quelconque donc là la réussite tient
aussi au fait que l'on soit avec un
équilibre familial vraiment de qualité
c'est une donnée fondamentale alors
justement tu parles d'émotion la
stabilité ouhlala l'équilibré émotionnel
la perche est trop forte
du côté neurosciences évolution des
neurosciences côté commercial moi j'ai
une tendance à dire que maintenant on
prend une décision que sous un aspect
émotionnel
comment ça interfère combien ça commence
à intervient dans une gestion de la
négociation ses dimensions émotionnelles
comment tu vois ça alors aussi
paradoxale que ça pourrait être c'est
parce qu'on a de plus en plus formalisé
la méthodologie c'est à dire que l'on a
créé en fait des process hyper efficace
la commande a enfin qu s'occuper de la
question des émotions du négociateur et
de celui qui rentre dans une complexité
des relatiosn elle il ya une multitude
de facteurs qui influencent ces facteurs
là ils sont avant tout une stimulation
et une une conviction que l'on a
individuel c'est à dire qu'on se
conditionnent littéralement pour
optimiser nos capacités et donc la
grande nouveauté c'est que autrefois on
allait chercher des choses extérieures
qui allait nous servir et non pour être
efficace aujourd'hui on sait qu'il ya
des ressources internes en puissance qui
sont colossales
et il suffit déjà de commencer à
travailler avec ces ressources là pour
optimiser donc notre notre savoir-faire
notre capacité d'accor
donc c'est très clair
l'évolution de ce métier parce que
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés à des
gens qui ont des visions et justement
qui ont des ressorts complètement
différent est-ce qu'on peut négocier
avec tout le monde et dans ce cas là
quand on tombe sur des individus qui ont
d'autres références à la fois culturel
évidemment mais surtout qui ne sont plus
dans une dimension habituel moment comme
on fait alors deux questions mais ce qui
a été le principal écueil en matière de
résolution de crise c'est les personnes
qui sont avec une psychopathologie là à
ce moment là et bien on sait très bien
que le fait d'être hors raisons hors
champ de la raison et bien c'est
extrêmement donc perturbante
préjudiciable à une résolution pacifique
parce que là où on arrive à convaincre
les personnes là où on arrive à les
influencer par une multitude de détails
successifs très procès c'est quelqu'un
qui est dans un autre monde qui est
délirant ne voit pas les réalités donc
du coup ne subit pas les mêmes types d'
influence donc il a fallu beaucoup
travailler sur la psychiatrie là dessus
et on sait très bien que c'est un écueil
très important en revanche
fondamentalement je pense que on peut
essayer de négocier avec tout le monde
d'accord il y en a qui la dimension
religieuse mais aussi bien aujourd'hui
là on est prêt que lesdits à l'emprise
d'une idéologie voilà donc là
l'empreinte est tellement forte
alors comment comment il faut faire
attention en fait à ne pas avoir non
plus à ne pas plaquer un préjugé quand
même un préjugé qui dit c'est impossible
tout simplement parce que la réaliser
c'est que peut-être peut-être que l'on
peut arriver donc à
dissuader la personne de passer à l'acte
tout de suite différer un passage à
l'acte tout j'ai mentionné le mans
éventuellement quand il ya un otage et
c'est à dire voilà que ça perturbe en
fait sont sont sombres desseins
criminels et donc je crois que il faut
essayer malgré tout malgré clan de de
laisser une possibilité de négocier à
chaque fois qu'on le peut parce que
sinon le coût est extrêmement élevé
si jamais on a donc quelques uns qui
fait sauter avec une ceinture
d'explosifs par exemple le groupe
d'intervention qui est souvent très près
de l'individu donc risque de subir des
dommages colossaux donc on doit je pense
tenter une résolution pacifique à chaque
fois qu'on le peut après quand ça marche
pas pas ma foi on a fait le job quoi on
a tenté cet aspect là ça marche pas mais
la loi a prévu des modes de
neutralisation et puis d'intervention
qui sont beaucoup plus vulnérables c'est
comme ça donc c'est en conclusion ce
serait quoi une bonne négociation si
c'est facile à dire sur son sol une
bonne négociation c'est quelqu'un qui en
face s'est persuadé qu'au fond sont les
options qu'il avait au départ ne sont
pas acceptables ne sont pas acceptables
en l'état et qui est content au fond du
résultat négocier après coup donc il
faut qu'il y ait une dimension de je
n'avais pas pensé à ça mais au fond
c'est pas mal voilà accord c'est cette
relation qui est pas complètement père à
l'enjeu transfert d'eau si le
tu es trop d'accord un grand respect
également vis-à-vis de la personne parce
que très souvent lorsque l'on perd on
est humilié
on se sent en colère parce qu'on n'a pas
eu la force suffisante tous les
arguments qu'il fallait où le poids les
convois de dire non et pourtant par une
bonne négociation on peut vraiment
s'affranchir de ce genre de choses et
faire en sorte que la personne
ressortent plus tôt on va dire
satisfaite de cette relation
aujourd'hui comment est-ce que tu mettes
toute cette somme de connaissances et de
et d'études sur ces sujets au service
d'entreprises ou de ou d'autres corps de
de l'état qui quel est ton en activité
principale aujourd'hui
donc aujourd'hui je suis à la tête de
plusieurs entreprises qui toutes sont
dans des domaines différents certaines
dans le domaine de la sécurité mais pas
que également on est sur des projets au
plan européen sur la protection des
biens des choses comme ça où la
protection des oeuvres d'art en zone de
guerre et il accompagne dans mon cabinet
principal les entrepreneurs les équipes
de direction et les managers en au sens
large sur l'amélioration de leurs
performances sur leur capacité de
négociation sur le commandement sur
l'influencé également sur le risque
judiciaire sur la gestion de crise la
communication de crise donc une
multitude de domaines qui rentrent qui
sont complètement dans le spectre en
fait de cette expérience passée d'accord
très très bien merci infiniment de cet
échange on peut retrouver aussi
christophe régulièrement sur les chaînes
de télévision et puis des ouvrages
également que tu oui il a écrit soit
donc directement donc comme négociateur
au cri au raid ou petit guide de contre
manipulation mais également beaucoup de
participation à des hauts gradés ouvrage
collectif avec un très grand nombre
d'auteurs et notamment donc d professeur
de neurosciences
j'ai vu quelques uns et ouvrages avec un
titre plus optimiste aussi oui en effet
alors jugé plus exactement le titre en
tête mais c'est fait avec des grands
noms comme rivaux cyrulnik par exemple
se tourner vers des girelles de
l'optimisme
oui c'est important ah la la la
résolution de grand nombre de trains de
conflit passe aussi par une dimension
donc de croire tout voir en la
possibilité de résoudre les choses
pacifiquement merci infiniment
christophe caupenne alors si nous avoir
rejoints
christophe est l'exemple même des
intervenants de très haut niveau que
nous recevons ici à lille lyne business
club le temps de déjeuner c'est à la
fois hyper enrichissant captivant
parfois frustrant parce qu'on aura envie
que ça dure plus longtemps
vous pouvez nous retrouver sur le site
yves in business club et notre prochain
a vite et nous restons dans une
dimension également de management de
très haut niveau patrick dutartre qui
est un ancien patron de la patrouille de
france
merci à vous merci à vous tous
[Musique]
à